I am a neuroscientist with a mixed
background in physics and medicine my
lab at the Swiss Federal Institute of
Technology focuses on spinal cord injury
which affect more than 50,000 people
around the world every year with
chromatic consequences for affected
individuals whose life literally shadows
in a matter of a handful of seconds and
for me the Man of Steel Christopher
Reeve as best raised awareness on the
distress of spinal cord injured people
and this is how I started my own
personal journey in this field of
research working with the Christopher
and Dana Reeve Foundation I still
remember this decisive moment it was
just at the end of a regular day of work
with the foundation Chris addressed was
a scientist and X first you have to be
more pragmatic when live in your
laboratory tomorrow I want you to stop
by the rehabilitation center to watch
injured people fighting to take a step
struggling to maintain the trunk and
when you go home think of what you are
going to change in your research on the
following day to make their life better
this world they stuck with me
this was more than ten years ago but
ever since my laboratory has followed
the pragmatic approach to recovery after
spinal cord injury and my first step in
this direction was to develop a new
model of spinal cord injury that would
more closely mimic some of the key
feature of human injury while offering
well control experimental condition and
for this purpose we placed women's
section on opposite side of the body the
completely interrupt the communication
between the brain and the spinal cord
thus living to a complete and permanent
paralysis of the leg but as observed
after most injuries in human there is
this intervening gap in technical issue
through which recovery can
but who to make it happen well the
classical approach consists of applying
intervention that will promote the
growth of the severed fiber to the
original target and well this certainly
remain the key for cure this seemed
extraordinary complicated to me to reach
clinical fruition rapidly it was obvious
I had to think about the problem
differently turned out that more than
100 years of research in spinal cord
physiology starting with a Nobel Prize
Sherrington shown that the spinal cord
below most injury contain all the
necessary and sufficient neuronal
network to coordinate locomotion
but because input from the brain are
interrupted there are in a
non-functional state a kind of dormant
my ID we awaken this network and at the
time I was a postdoctoral fellow in Los
Angeles after completing my PhD in
France where independent thinking is not
necessarily promoted I was afraid to
talk to my new boss but decided to
muster up my courage I knock at the door
my wonderful adviser Reggie Edgerton to
share my new idea he listened to me
carefully and respond with a grin why
don't you try and I promise to you this
was such an important moment in my
career when I realized that the great
leader believed in young people and new
idea and this was the idea I'm going to
use a simplistic metaphor to explain you
this complicated concept imagine that
the locomotor system is a car the engine
is a spinal cord the transmission is
interrupted the engine is turned off how
could we engage the engine first we have
to provide the fuel second press the
accelerator pedal third steal the car it
turned out that there are neural
pathways coming from the brain that
played this very
function during locomotion my ID
replaced this missing input provide the
spinal cord with a kind of inter version
that the brain would deliver naturally
in order to walk for this I'll erase 20
years of past research in neuroscience
first to replace the missing fuel with
pharmacological agents that prepare the
neuron in the spinal cord to fire and
second to mimic the accelerator pedal
with electrical stimulation so a imagina
electrode implanted on the back of the
spinal cord to deliver painless
stimulation took many years but
eventually we developed an
electrochemical neural prosthesis that
cruciform the neural network in the
spinal cord from dormant to highly
functional state immediately the
paralyzed rat can stand as soon as the
treadmill Bell start moving the animal
who coordinated movement of the leg but
without the brain here what I called the
spinal brain cognitively process his
source of information arising from the
moving leg and take decision as to halt
to activate the muscle in order to stand
to walk to run and even here while
sprinting instantly stent is a treadmill
bell stopped moving
it was amazing I was completely
fascinated by this locomotion with of
the brain but at the same time so
frustrated his locomotion was completely
involuntary the animal at virtually no
control over the legs
clearly the steering system was missing
and even became obvious to me that we
had to move away from the classical
rehabilitation paradigm stepping on a
treadmill and developed condition that
would encourage the brain to regain of
voluntary control over the leg with this
in mind we developed a completely new
robotic system to support the rats in
any direction of space imagine this is
really cool
so you imagine the little 200 gram rat
attached at the extremity of this 200
kilo robot but the rat does not fill the
robot the robot is transparent just like
you would hold a young child during the
first in sexual steps
let me summarize the rat received a
paralyzing lesion of the sparrow taught
the electrochemical neural processes
enable highly functional state of the
spinal locomotor networks the robot
provides a safe environment to allow the
rat Wotton anything to engage the
paralyzed legs and for motivation we use
what I think is the more powerful
pharmacology of Switzerland fine Swiss
chocolate actually the first result were
very very very disappointing here is my
best physical therapist completely
failing to operate the right to take a
single step whereas the same rat five
minutes earlier worked beautifully on
the treadmill who are so frustrated you
know one of the most essential quality
of a scientist is perseverance we
insisted we we find our paradigm and
after several month of training the
otherwise paralyzed rat could stand
whenever she decided initiated full
weight being locomotion to sprint toward
the reward this is the first recovery
ever observed of voluntary leg movement
after an experimental lesion of the
spinal cord leading to complete and
permanent paralysis in fact
thank you
in fact not only the rat could initiate
and sustain locomotion over ground they
could even add just like movement for
example to resist gravity in order to
climb a staircase I can promise you this
was such an emotional moment in my
laboratory it took us 10 years of hard
work to reach this goal but the
remaining question was how who is it
possible and here what we found was
completely unexpected
this novel training Prada
uncrate the brain to create new
connections some realized secrets that
relay information from the brain past
the injury and restore the article
control over the local motor networks
bureaus you injury and here you can see
one such example where we label the
fibers coming from the brain in red this
blue neuron is connected with la quwata
Center and what this constellation of
synaptic contacts means is that the
brain is reconnected with locomotor
Center with only one relay neurone but
the remodeling was not restricted to the
lesion area it occurred throughout the
central nervous system including in the
brainstem where we observe up to 300%
increase in the density of fibers coming
from the brain we did not aim to repair
the spinal cord yet we were able to
promote one of the more extensive
remodeling of axonal projection ever
observed in the central nervous system
of adult mammal after an injury and no
there is a very important message hidden
behind this discovery the other result
of a young team of very talented people
physical therapists neurobiologist
neurosurgeon engineer of all kinds who
have achieved together what would have
been impossible by single individuals
this is truly a transdisciplinary team
they are working so close to each other
that there is always on tile transfer of
DNA we are creating the next generation
of MDS an engineer capable of
translating discoveries all the way from
bench to bedside and me I am only the
maestro
walk straight this beautiful Stephanie
no I am sure you are all wondering not
you will this help injured people me too
nowaday truth is that we don't know
enough yet this is certainly not a cure
for spinal cord injury but I begin to
believe that this may get to an
intervention to improve recovery and
people's quality of life I would like
you all to take a moment and dream with
me imagine a person just suffered spinal
cord injury after a few weeks of
recovery we will implant a programmable
pump to deliver a personalized
pharmacological cocktail directly to the
spinal cord at the same time we will
implant an electrode array a thought of
second skin covering the area of the
spinal cord controlling leg movement and
this array is attached to an electrical
pulse generator that deliver stimulation
that are tailored to the person's need
this design of personalized
electrochemical neural prosthesis that
will enable locomotion during training
with a newly designed supporting system
and my hope is that after several month
of training they may be enough
remodeling a residual connection to a
locomotion without the robot maybe even
without pharmacology of stimulation my
hope here is to be able to create the
personalized condition to boost the
plasticity of the brain and the spinal
cord and
is a radically new concept that may
apply to other neurological disorder
what I termed personalized neural
prosthetics whereby sensing and
stimulating neural interfaces implanted
throughout the nervous system in the
brain in the spinal cord even in
peripheral nerves based on patient
specific impairments but not to replace
the loss function now to help the brain
help itself and I hope this enticed your
imagination because I can promise to you
this is not a matter of whether this
revolution will occur but when and
remember we are only as great as our
imagination as big as our dream thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]